à la rentrée au four comme dans des
milliers de petites écoles en france le
directeur d'école pourrait disparaître
c'est le sens du projet de la loi
bancaire votée en février dernier un
amendement prévoit la création
d'établissements publics des savoirs
fondamentaux
une structure qui regrouperait plusieurs
écoles avec son collège de rattachement
ou super école dirigée par un seul chef
d'établissement le principal du collège
principal il va se retrouver à gérer son
collège +56 cette école gérée et 1000
2000 peut-être 3000 élèves aux fonctions
des cas et on voit bien dira un parent
d'un enfant de trois ans qui arrivent en
début d'année le parent à une
réclamation à faire qui on le dira pas
non faut aller voir au collège malraux à
10 km vous prenez rendez vous quoi c'est
pas humain
dans ce village de moyenne montagne
cette nouvelle organisation ne passe pas
en protestation l'école sera fermée
demain les enseignants en grève seront
soutenus par les familles attachées à ce
service indispensable de proximité je
n'ai pas de voiture je dois aller voir
le directeur parce que mon enfant un
souci d ici deux enfants je sais pas
comment ce fait réduire la rupture entre
premier et second degrés et permettra de
petites écoles d'atteindre la taille
critique
voilà les arguments affichée par les
rapporteurs de la loi mais pour les
syndicats cette mesure permet surtout à
l'état de réaliser des économies et de
justifier la suppression de postes par
rapport aux écoles des classes qui vont
devenir encore plus importantes parce
que les effectifs vont être calculée sur
la base des grosses structures
donc on risque d'avoir des fermetures de
classes qui ont réuni tout le monde
à métabief par exemple l'ouverture d'une
dixième classe serait remise en cause
à la rentrée les effectifs passeraient
de 24 à 27 par classe
avec cet amendement le projet de loi
dite école de la confiance pourrait donc
devenir celui de la méfiance